[Musik]
in ordnung so machen wir es vielen
vielen dank
ja ich auch und ab nächster woche bist
du offiziell in der filmbranche tätig
cool
und du sagst es ist eine serie was nur
noch mehr darüber worum geht es es ist
eine krimiserie aber nicht so ernst
männer krimikomödie eine krimikomödie
komödie oma comedia in der serie geht es
um einen kommissar der mit seinem gegner
zusammenarbeiten muss meistens ist das
sehr komisch hin und wieder wird es aber
auch tragisch ich schaue die serie
eigentlich ganz gern wenn gerade keine
dokus laufen das klingt eher spannend
ich glaube sogar das drehbuch basiert
auf einem roman
die serie ist also eine buchverfilmung
und wo läuft die serie im fernsehen und
im internet auch glaube ich gut dann
fange ich gleich an die serie zu schauen
sehr gute vorbereitung ist wichtig
filmbranche